[Musique]
et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
gérez me pelletier bonjour bienvenue sur
ce plateau merci d'être là pour évoquer
l'élection présidentielle comme tous les
lundis désormais et ce jusqu'au 10 avril
vous êtes enfin vous ne serez pas là
tous les lundis mais c'est ce qu'on fait
en tout cas faire tous les lundis vous
êtes chercheur direct directeur des
études à la fondation jean jaurès on
peut vous lis régulièrement dans
marianne et vous avez signé il ya
quelques temps la fête est finie point
d'interrogation sorti aux éditions de
l'observatoire enquête on ne peut plus
sérieux sur les traces de notre sens de
la fête qui serait comme la politique à
la fois nulle part et partout autour de
nous on y reviendra tout à l'heure
d'abord si vous le voulez bien on va
revenir ensemble sur l'actualité
politique du week end qui a été
relativement peu animée marquée
toutefois par la guerre d extrême droite
qui se poursuit entre marine le pen et
eric zemmour qui sont au coude à coude
dans les sondages qui al'avantage selon
vous
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile à dire
effectivement il ya un premier sondage
ce week-end qui vient de montrer que
c'était la première fois que marine le
pen eric zemmour était au coude à coude
était à à 14 % chacun il ya une bataille
effectivement pour réussir à obtenir 15
16% des voix qui devient en fait
maintenant dans une élection
présidentielle a beaucoup de candidats
le seuil assez faible finalement pour
passer au second tour donc il ya une
bataille serrée jusqu'à la fin les uns
et les autres vont vouloir se voler un
certain nombre de sympathisants vouloir
se voler un certain nombre de figures
pour les ralliements on parle beaucoup
et vous savez de marion maréchal-le pen
qui pourrait rejoindre potentiellement
eric zemmour mots finalement c'est cette
série un petit peu télé c'est cette
série un petit peu politique qui va
animer finalement le
l'ensemble de cette campagne
présidentielle la question c'est est-ce
que ça intéresse vraiment le grand
public est ce que c'est cette petite
guerre entre deux figures de l'extrême
droite qui va intéresser le grand public
je ne suis pas convaincu mais on verra
ça d'ici le premier tour on garde la
réponse pendant un instant de l'extrême
droite à l'extrême gauche on parle
également de plus en plus du candidat
communiste fabien roussel dents moindres
proportions il l'a tenu son premier
meeting national à marseille hier
campagne qui détonne à gauche avec des
thèmes notamment sur le nucléaire est ce
qui peut créer une forme surprise fabien
roussel en tout cas c'est un des rares
qui arrive à créer un discours original
un discours nouveau effectivement dans
cette campagne c'est très frappant de
voir que le nombre de sujets en fait qui
arrive dans la campagne sont souvent
liés à des éléments qui sont en dehors
du politique c'est un livre et la
publication d'un livre qui met le sujet
des ehpad et le sujet du vieillissement
dans le débat public c'est parfois des
séries c'est parfois des films qui
mettent désormais les sujets politiques
finalement dans le débat public fabien
roussel lui il est parvenu effectivement
à travers le nucléaire mais aussi avec
l'alimentation le le sujet du bien
manger à être un des rares finalement
responsables politiques dans cette
campagne à mettre des sujets dans le
débat public donc pour le coup c'est
l'une de ses grandes qualités c'est un
des rares qui a gagné autant en terme de
notoriété parce qu'il était totalement
inconnu du grand public avant
effectivement le début de cette campagne
il fait une campagne originale dans le
ton dans le style dans la forme et ça
serait effectivement historique entre
guillemets alors on parle là des des
seuils très marron parle de 3 à 4 5% 6%
d'intentions de vote mais ce serait
historique si demain à l'issue du
premier tour de la présidentielle le
candidat communiste serait en tête face
au à la candidate ps serait quelque
chose d'historique effectivement que
françois mitterrand avait
modifié et là on sort est finalement un
retour 40 ans en arrière sur quelque
chose d'assez fouet parce que la
candidat socialiste est crédité d'à peu
près autant en ce moment que fabien
roussel la première fois que le parti
communiste présenter un candidat depuis
15 ans sauf que voilà j'ai à me
pelletier en réalité cette campagne si
elle nous intéresse peut-être nous des
formations professionnelles intéresse
assez peu les français well intéresse
assez peu les français quand on regarde
par rapport à la même période en février
2017 on a perdu 10 points à peu près
d'intérêt pour la campagne
présidentielle quand vous demandez aux
français où est ce que cette campagne
vous intéresse et ce que vous êtes
intéressé par la prochaine élection
présidentielle vous avez dit point
effectivement d'intérêt de moins par
rapport à février 2010 est quand vous
regardez les conversations des français
on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que 55 52 %
seulement des français disent avoir
parlé de la campagne avec leurs proches
lors de déjeuners lors des dîners au
cours de la semaine passée à la même
époque en 2010 est on était à 8 français
sur 10 qui avait parlé de la campagne
donc finalement pour un français sur
deux la campagne présidentielle n'est
pas un sujet ce n'est pas quelque chose
d'important en tout cas ce n'est pas un
objet de discussion avec les proches et
avec ses amis alors que pour le coup
c'était massivement le cas en 2017 lors
de la campagne présidentielle en 2017
pourquoi c'est très difficile
aujourd'hui je crois de distinguer le
moment d'une campagne présidentielle
avec le moment d'une non campagne
présidentielle beaucoup disent 'vous
savez la campagne n'imprime pas on
n'arrive pas finalement à s'accrocher à
cette campagne là mais parce que
finalement depuis 2010 est en fait une
espèce de campagne permanente il ya des
espèces de tour de france permanent vous
vous souvenez de la séquence autour des
gilets jaunes autour du grand débat
finalement vous aviez le sentiment que
tous les responsables politiques étaient
déjà en campagne en permanence ils sont
en campagne tous les matins dans les
matinales tous les soirs dans les
émissions politiques et finalement ils
ont une succession de canaux pour
s'exprimer en permanence qui fait que
sur par exemple une semaine de campagne
un candidat va peut-être aujourd'hui
faire 20 interview 25 interview entre la
presse écrite la radio le numérique et
donc c'est très difficile en fait d'être
original c'est très difficile d'arriver
avec une proposition où les uns et les
autres vous dise ah ouais là il ya
quelque chose que je n'avais pas encore
entendu il ya quelque chose de nouveau
de 9 et c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs vous avez une partie des
candidats qu'ils prennent d'anciennes
propositions qui donne d'ailleurs le
sentiment que c'est une campagne un peu
de réchauffer quand j'entends
effectivement valérie pécresse parlez
vous savez du catcheur de la sortie de
nouveaux du karcher bas vous avez le
sentiment que ils viennent puiser dans
des anciennes recettes ils viennent
puiser dans quelque chose d'un peu has
been parce que c'est très difficile de
toute façon d'apparaître original dans
un flux permanent de débattre campagne
pourtant des polémiques des
personnalités saillantes je pense à eric
zemmour notamment des nouveautés des
propositions démocratique je pense à la
primaire populaire il y en a il y a de
quoi peut-être aiguisé l'appétit de
l'envi de politique non ouais après vous
savez ce qu'on avait analysé un peu
après les régionales et le départemental
avec effectivement cessé taux
d'abstention très important c'était que
on peut considérer qu'il ya une espèce
de crise de foi aussi républicaine
aujourd'hui dans le pays et que dans un
pays accéléré beaucoup ici par le
confinement accélérer aussi beaucoup par
la crise sanitaire qui a eu tendance à
se recroqueviller sur sa sphère privée
sur sa sphère personnelle à privilégier
beaucoup finalement le bonheur
domestique le bonheur de sa vie
familiale
ce qui est très intéressant que vous
regardez les enquêtes c'est congo les
gens ne disent pas vivre moins bien que
lors de la campagne présidentielle
globalement il ya un espèce d'optimiste
indivise optimisme par dons individuels
qui reste encore très important dans le
steak française et un pessimisme
collectif était aux mains de fois
documenté et qui est pas nouveau mais
l'optimisme un duel fait que finalement
bas vous avez aujourd'hui le même taux
de gens qui sont satisfaits de leur vie
qu on mesurait déjà effectivement en
février 2010 est donc moi je pense qu'il
ya une petite crise de foi effectivement
et républicaine que pour de plus en plus
de françaises et des français la vie
politique est devenue quelque chose d'un
peu parallèle un univers parallèle et
finalement la façon dont la crise a été
gérée peut donner aussi le sentiment un
certain nombre de français que bon
finalement qui que ce soit aujourd'hui à
la tête de la présidence de la
république en cas de crise majeure bon
bah un candidat de gauche peut faire un
programme de droite un programme de 1
candidat de droite peut faire une
politique de gauche et donc tout ça
effectivement a tendance à brouiller les
pistes et vous donner le sentiment que
la machine de toute façon tournera quoi
qu'il arrive ça ça veut dire qu'ils
manuel macron du coup et
éco-responsable quoi de cette lassitude
qui dépasse le moment de la campagne bas
il ya quelque chose qui préexistait
effectivement à son arrivée d'ailleurs
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
il a réussi aussi aussi à gagner je
pense que si il est responsable de
quelque chose c'est d'avoir créé un
espace politique très illisible
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile pour
les françaises et les français de se
positionner par exemple quand on regarde
les cartes vous savez qui sont affichées
sur la télévision à l'issue des scrutins
à l'issue des scrutins municipaux à
l'issue des scrutins d arte e manteau
régionaux avant c'était très simple à
cartel était divisée en deux le rose
d'un côté pour la gauche et le ps le
bleu d'un côté pour la droite et les
républicains aujourd'hui l'arrivée dans
marché vous bouleverser en fait cette
structuration du débat public ça créé
une forme d'illisibilité et et
d'incompréhension aussi par rapport aux
candidats qui se présentent vous avez un
certain nombre de gens qui vous disent
j'arrive dans le bureau de vote et je ne
comprends pas finalement qu'est lire
l'étiquette du candidat pour qui je vais
voter il l'a des deals avec la
république en marche à l'échelle
nationale et à l'échelle locale il a des
deals avec le ps donc tout ça crée
effectivement de l'incompréhension des
visibilités et donc évidement une forme
de retrait aussi de la part des citoyens
qui ne comprennent plus forcément aussi
le jeu politique tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui vous parliez de ces français
a fatigué après deux ans d'épidémie peut
être optimiste sur leur sphère privée
beaucoup moins sur la sphère ou en tout
cas dans la halle en collectif ça fait
peser quoi ça comme risque sur la sur la
démocratie bah effectivement quand vous
interrogez aujourd'hui les français
l'élément qui ressort très souvent c'est
la fatigue que vous leur demandez quels
sont les traits caractéristiques quels
sont les termes qui définissent le mieux
leur état d'esprit effectivement le
terme de la faune de fatigue il est
apparu massivement durant la crise donc
globalement les français se disent
fatigués individuellement et surtout se
disent fatigués collectivement et en
gros cette espèce d'apathie individuel
cette espèce d'apathie personnel cette
espèce de sentiment de fatigue personnel
elle peut se traduire par une apathie
ensuite collective elle peut se traduire
ensuite par une des filles comme une
fatigue collective et la fatigue
collectif c'est un retrait vis-à-vis de
l'engagement c'est une fatigue de la
compassion aussi finalement on est de
moins en moins intéressés par les
affaires du monde de pavant entre
guillemets la misère du monde dont je
crois que cette fatigue de la compassion
c'est un élément très important aussi
pour expliquer le retrait vis-à-vis de
la vie politique et la fatigue collectif
ça peut aussi se traduire évidemment par
de l'abstention aujourd'hui on table à
peu près entre 25 et 30 % d'abstention
au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle rappelle on était à un
peu plus de 20% à 21 % au premier tour
en 2010 est normalement l'élection
présidentielle est à peu près préservé
effectivement à par rapport à des taux
de participation qui reste très
important à ce stade on s'interroge
effectivement si on ne va pas vers
quelque chose qui serait de l'ordre de
30 % d'abstention au premier tour ce qui
serait très important puis rapidement
pour conclure les français sont fatigués
mais les français sont préoccupés il ya
bien sûr des sujets qui les inquiète je
pas bien sûr le covin le pouvoir d'achat
et puis vous parlez des gilet jaune tout
ailleurs tout à l'heure cette colère
sociale qui s'est exprimé il ya un peu
plus de deux ans elle n'a pas disparu
est-ce qu'elle va s'exprimer ce qu'elle
peut s'exprimer là dans deux mois et si
oui auprès de qui là vous l'avez dit le
fait que le pouvoir d'achat soit aussi
aujourd'hui dans les préoccupations
alors montre un élément qui est que le
chômage a baissé en fait c'est très
intéressant à chaque fois où vous
regardez les enquêtes dès que le chômage
a tendance à baisser le pouvoir d'achat
reprend finalement la première place en
termes de préoccupation et quand le
chômage est importante effectivement le
pouvoir d'achat est relégué en 2ème 3ème
position le fait que le pouvoir d'achat
soit au coeur aussi de la campagne sont
au coeur des préoccupations c'est
l'illustration aussi que ce que
revendique et une partie des jaunes est
encore très présent c'était beaucoup lit
effectivement à haut pouvoir d'achat à
la façon dont deux un certain nombre de
public ne pouvait plus aujourd'hui
consommé ne pouvait plus participer à la
cité de consommation telle qu'on la
connaît donc il s'illustre à mon sens à
travers ça et le fait qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez deux candidats d'extrême
droite aussi haut eric zemmour et marine
le pen sont aussi à mon sens
l'expression est l'illustration de ce
ras-le-bol qu'on avait pu sentir pour
nos régions merci beaucoup il y avait
beaucoup de choses à dire merci beaucoup
géré méritait d'être venu ce matin sur
le plateau de paris direct on vous
retrouve dans marianne et bien sûr
toutes vos études pour la fondation jean
jaurès très belle journée on se retrouve